STEPHANIE WONG: Training
a machine learning model
involves testing a
variety of parameters
to figure out which
configuration works best.
Before you even start
training a model,
you'll need to set up
some hyperparameters,
like the number of epochs
you want to train for
or the type of optimization
function you want to use.
But it can be tricky to figure
out which values will give you
the results you want.
Let's take a look at
what hyperparameters are
and how Katib can
help you tune them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today we'll talk
about hyperparameters
and how to use Katib for
hyperparameter tuning.
If you want to check out
the documentation directly,
check out the link below
to read more about Katib
and how to use it.
Unlike the training parameters
that are tested and adjusted
during the training
phase, hyperparameters
aren't learned by the model.
They're provided before
you begin training and can
make a big impact on the
results of your model.
You could try adjusting
them yourself,
changing hyperparameters,
and noting the results.
But when you have many
different configurations
you want to explore
and training your model
takes a significant
amount of time,
it's not feasible
to do it yourself.
That's where Katib
comes in to help.
Katib helps tune
your hyperparameters
by testing a range of
values for each one.
You need to define what
your objective is, and then
set up an experiment
so Katib can
try different
hyperparameter values.
For example, if you are
training a model with two
hyperparameters-- learning
rate and batch size--
and wanted to
maximize the accuracy,
Katib could run the experiment
to try different values
and see how they
affect your objective.
You could also try
different objectives,
like minimizing error rate.
Let's walk through
actually running Katib.
You can try this
out for yourself
if you have a Kubeflow
instance running.
Just head to the dashboard,
choose your namespace,
and then click Katib on
the left side, followed
by Hyperparameter Tuning.
This should give you
a big text box where
you can paste a YAML file.
We'll include a link
in the description
for the one we're using here.
So go ahead and copy-paste the
file here, and then hit Deploy.
This can take a while to
run, so let's take a look
at some of the configuration
we're specifying.
Here we're defining some key
values with our trial accounts.
Each trial is an iteration
through the experiment with one
set of hyperparameter values.
This whole file will create
one experiment with 12 trials,
as specified in
the maxTrialCount.
In addition, Kubeflow will
run three trials in parallel,
thanks to the
parallelTrialCount.
And maxFailedTrialCount will
shut down the experiment
if three of the trials
result in failure.
In addition, we're also
specifying the objective
we're looking for.
In this case, we want to
maximize the accuracy_1 metric.
A goal of 0.99 is
also specified,
so the experiment
will automatically
stop if we hit 99% accuracy.
Lastly, we can specify
which algorithm Katib
will use to tune the
hyperparameter values.
Multiple algorithms
are supported,
such as grid search or
Bayesian optimization,
but we'll keep things simple
with the random algorithm.
In this case,
Katib will randomly
try different values
for our hyperparameters
and measure our
objective metric.
Let's take a look at
the hyperparameters
in the configuration file.
These are the actual
hyperparameters
we want to test.
In this case, we're looking
at testing the learning rate
and batch size for
our training step.
Each hyperparameter has a
type, along with a feasible
range of values with
minimums and maximums.
Since we specified
random as our algorithm,
Katib will choose random
values for these two
inside the feasibleSpace and
then run the training job
as a single trial.
Once we've hit
the maxTrialCount,
our experiment
should be finished.
We can check the status
by selecting the Menu
icon next to Katib and
choosing HP, then Monitor.
You'll see a list
of any experiment
and their current status.
A check mark means the
experiment has completed
successfully, and we can click
on it to see more information.
This graph can look a
little bit complicated,
but it's actually just
showing you each trial
over the entire experiment.
The left column is a result
of our objective metric,
the middle column is
the learning rate,
and the right column
is our batch size.
If we look at the line that
had the highest accuracy,
we can see the values
of our hyperparameters
that lead to this run.
It can be a bit hard to
see the exact values here,
so if you scroll down,
you can see a table
with all the trials.
Looks like the best learning
rate was around 0.0111
and the batch size
was 170, giving us
an accuracy of just over 97%.
In this case, we
only used 12 trials,
but we can easily
change the YAML file
and try another experiment
with more trials
or additional hyperparameters.
Katib can help save you
a lot of time and effort
in narrowing down
the best values
for your hyperparameters.
And it's easy to set
up an experiment.
Try it out for yourself, and
check out the documentation
and read more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]